e tu qualcosa
[Musica]
e questa ci mancava pure la cosa
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
avete capito che sono venuto a trovare
qua sopra per la chiedere aiuto al lupo
lui sicuramente saprà aiutarci e no
spero proprio di sì ecco vi ricordate di
questa porta il lupo vive proprio qua
dentro
anita aveva già provato a bussare qui a
chiedere il suo aiuto
quindi adesso ci troviamo che noi signor
lupo cosa sta facendo
aprendo il lucchetto signore un po salve
signor gruppo possa disturbarla
all'istante bisogno del suo aiuto per
per salvare la vita e come si sta si sta
trasformando in un nuovo mandato e
vorrebbe proporre questa trasformazione
e può aiutare per questo era un sì lì è
come te deve essere stata morsa da un po
da un lupo mannaro
ed è così che è iniziata la
trasformazione cosa stai facendo
[Musica]
sembra che stia scrivendo su un foglio
ma cos'è non capisco cosa dice proviamo
a leggere questo foglio
mi dispiace sono stato io a morderla è
stato lui a mordere anita l'ora di
iniziare la trasformazione ma stavo sole
seguendo degli ordini e di chi però ora
che il mio capo non mi vede posso
aiutarti segui bene queste indicazioni
[Musica]
ehi ma domandato a vita o o come dire
che sta tentando di scappare
devo andare a fermarla se sono ancora in
tempo
[Musica]
tu sei andato ad anita qui non si vede
dove si sarà nascosta il quinto
non c'è chi aspetta un attimo quello
cos'è ma che ci fai la sua nasce un
rimpasto devo saltare dal muretto ed
alberi pietà può saltare dal momento no
non puoi andare ti farai male è
altissimo il muro brano mi faccio perché
perché sono meta al lupo aspetta aspetta
aspetta ci farò morte nel mio braccio mi
dispiace ma non puoi fermarmi ora che
sono mete al lupo e sta per arrivare in
una piena devo andare a cercarsela
corrente
addio no no no aspetta aspetta aspetta a
diventare non andare troppo e ti farò
dare un mostro al mio braccio se scendi
subito dal muretto
ok ho vissuto il proprio e no prima devi
scendere ed entrare dentro casa insieme
alla quindi ti farai mordere trasformare
il lupo mannaro anche tu sì lo farò non
vincerà il forno fuori troverò molti più
breve e no e dovrai cercarle le prede e
le dovrei trasformare e invece io sono
già qua ti basta un porto mezzo ha
trasformato da io sono vitale poi
diventerò un lupo mannaro li metteremo
alleati e prenderemo mio prete no ma
solo quel che faccio più in fretta
trasformarti che andiamo dai
adesso l'inter in casa che supporti
board rip si guarda dovreste un attimo
allungare quel cassetto lì ma per quel
cassetto per qualcosa non aver paura
davvero guardare troppo fredde vinci
brutta luna piena star 4t fatto fare un
modo di sera voi da il primo baby le di
aria scappiamo scappiamo sono riuscito a
scappare o no una cosa faccio per
procedere secondo i piani
anita deve rimanere sotto controllo in
casa ma non posso di certo farmi mordere
però ho un piano
venite con me andiamo o no venite
scappata c'è la porta aperta come ha
fatto ad aprire la porta devo trovare la
subito prima che faccia delle altre
vittime non può uscire da sola fuori
scapperà di nuovo e prenderà qualcun
altro
[Musica]
e anita berlino e lista unita 6 dov'è
andata da quella parte
grazie a berlino
[Musica]
sì l'ho presa lo catturata
e adesso i mini crociera
si insapona dalle banche non mi stupirei
sono quasi deciso e chiuderlo
ci sono riuscito anche strano minuten
da bruxelles
[Musica]
[Risate]
su
[Musica]